In 1992 I did my master's thesis on a tool
that would take a program and visualize this
in various graphical forms.
I will produce correctly formatted text, flow charts,
or Nassi–Shneiderman diagrams.
And you'd even be able to edit these in an editor.
Later I went on pursuing my Ph.D.,
which I completed in 1997 on a topic named
configuration management with feature logic.
The idea was to use description logic to model
changes in variance and to detect inconsistencies.
This was pretty cool, but the problem was that
apparently no developer was willing to learn description logics.
Plus, configuration management was essentially
solved so I was disappointed.
That's when a student of mine, Dorothea Litkehaus, came along,
and we developed the idea to use
my old library for visualizing programs
to visualize data structures rather than programs.
Finally, I would be doing something useful.
The resulting tool became a debugger named DDD
for data display debugger.
This is what DDD looked like.
It had a command line interface
so you could enter arbitrary commands.
You'd also see the source code.
You would be able to set break points,
and see the current execution position.
The interesting thing however about DDD,
as the name says data display debugger,
was the ability to show data structures.
For instance, up here we have visualized that pointer list,
and now I can double click on the pointer to see where it points to.
This is the element the pointer points to.
I can check out what self points to.
Obviously, it points to itself.
I can look up the next value.
Again, look up self,
and again look up the next value
and see that the whole thing becomes actually a linked list.
Needless to say, as I keep on stepping through the program,
and as the values change,
the display would be updated automatically just as well.
DDD eventually became free software,
and was even adopted by the GNU project.
So it became GNU DDD,
and it became very popular with C and C++ programmers.
Today there is even python support build into DDD,
but I'm not maintaining this anymore
so I don't know how well this works.